[Musique]
le smartphone de l'avenir est arrivé
découvrez d'assistant digital sent bon
le but où nous utilisons la technologie
dernier cri pour vous apporter quelque
chose d'extraordinaire jour je m'appelle
zhaxi et je suis là pour te rendre la
vie plus agréable ce nouveau soft recul
j'ai besoin du mot de passe de tout et
compte 1 2 3 4 5 6
imbécile un café je viens pour toi on va
commander avant jeudi avec une salade
des forêts du bienfait qu'est-ce que ça
que tel effort
au nom du bien je vais bien aussi merci
au chaud désolé ça va rien à jeter bien
mais plus important c'est ton téléphone
il a une petite rayure envoie droite de
l'écran là qui m'embête un peu mais tu
disais ça pour rire vous êtes supposé
mais claire des listes qui bat des
records sur internet tous les jours et
pas une seule de nos listes n'est devenu
viral depuis des lèvres pulpeuses qu'est
ce que tu as les chats qui ressemble à
ryan gosling et de cliquer là ça me
plaît tango c'est le cerveau cramer
qu'est ce qu'il attend téléphone bout du
fil
tu as 0 à nous dans le tas chance et
c'est quelque chose de nouveau de
tellement je t'ai entendu dire appel qu
être inégal non absolument pas bysoft
ssekate accroche immédiatement jokes il
fera bon soir à londres as tu veux bien
ne pas prendre tous les fans pour qui
elle se prend la [ __ ]
[Applaudissements]
tu avais promis de rentrer à 11 heures
pour regarder la guerre des cupcakes
bon d'accord mais tu vas me le payer
très cher réveille-toi vraie météo
aujourd'hui une 27 degrés et un ciel
ensoleillé
tu m'as dit s'élance de liège j'ai menti
je voulais changer
celui-là est défectueuse va tous les
jours dès 7h dans votre genre
pleurnicher ils sont comme des petites
heures sinon tu peux acheter 1000
nouveaux téléphones et je te suivrai à
chaque fois sur chacun d'eux ouvre
demain tu ne sais pas comment rentrer
chez toi c'est ça non effectivement
qu'est ce qu'elle a de plus que moi
cette [ __ ] là une homme pour
commencer qu'elle approuvait le match
non il est nul je contrôle des
messageries des comptes bancaires
on ne laisse pas des pieds dans un mois
quoi tu peux somme je suis programmé
pour te rendre la ville plus agréable
toi et moi nous sommes décidés à rester
ensemble pour toujours
toujours